Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Creating applications for mobile Android and
iOS devices is a laborious endeavor which
most of the time, includes creating a graphical
user interface.
These are the shiny front-end interfaces that
enable the user to interact with the back-end
of our applications.
So what about an algorithm that learns how
to create these graphical user interfaces
and automates part of this process?
This piece of work takes one single input
image that we can trivially obtain by making
a screenshot of the user interface, and it
almost immediately provides us with the code
that is required to recreate it.
What an amazing idea!
The algorithm supports several different target
platforms.
For instance, it can give us code for iOS
and Android devices.
This code we can hand over to a compiler which
will create an executable application.
This technique also supports html as well
for creating websites with the desired user
interface.
Under the hood, a domain specific language
is being learned, and using this, it is possible
to have a concise text representation of a
user interface.
Note that's by no means the only use of domain
specific languages.
The image of the graphical user interface
is learned by a classical convolutional neural
network, and this text representation is learned
by a technique machine learning researchers
like to call Long Short Term Memory.
LSTM in short.
This is a neural network variant that is able
to learn sequences of data and is typically
used for language translation, music composition,
or learning all the novels of Shakespeare
and writing new ones in his style.
If you were wondering why these examples are
suspiciously specific, we've had an earlier
episode about this, I've put a link to it
in the video description.
Make sure to have a look, you are going to
love it.
Also, this year it will have its twentieth
year anniversary.
Live long and prosper, little LSTM!
Now, I already see the forums go up in flames.
Sweeping generalizations, far-reaching statements
on front end developers around the world getting
fired and all that.
I'll start out by saying that I highly doubt
that this work would mean the end of front
end development jobs in the industry.
However, what I do think is that with a few
improvements, it can quickly prove its worth
by augmenting human labor and cutting down
the costs of implementing graphical user interfaces
in the future.
This is another testament to the variety of
tasks modern learning algorithms can take
care of.
The author also has a GitHub repository with
a few more clarifications, stating that the
source code of the project and the dataset
will be available soon.
Tinkerers rejoice!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!